Rosalyn Smith was born in the small town
of Plains Georgia in 1927 her nextdoor
neighbor a three-year-old Jimmy Carter
the first day Rosen was alive I went
over next door to look at the little
girl who was a newborn baby on the
street so I I've known her ever since
the first day she was born the daughter
of an auto mechanic she faced tragedy at
a young age my father died when I was 13
um I was the oldest of four children I
had two brothers and a little sister
four years old uh my mother had never
written a check um it was a difficult
time for us but um I was put in charge
of the little children and that that was
hard she married Carter when she was 18
years old while raising her four
children she campaigned for her husband
to become the governor of Georgia and
later the 39th president of the United
States in 1977 so help me G in her role
as first lady she lobbied for more
government help for people with mental
illness and for senior citizens and she
actively supported the Equal Rights
Amendment for women which eventually
failed so did Jimmy Carter's reelection
bid suffering a bitter defeat to Ronald
Reagan in 1980 the Carters then took on
a new role as unofficial Goodwill
ambassadors they opened the Carter
Center which sends monitors around the
world to oversee
elections they met with leaders of
Nations hostile to the United States to
encourage better dialogue and promote a
greater respect for human rights
and the former first lady led efforts to
bring immunizations and health programs
to communities in the Caribbean and
Africa most of the time it's the first
thing they have ever seen that was
successful and it's just so wonderful
just to see the Hope on their faces that
something good is
happening I didn't mean to get emotional
also in her later years Champion the
causes for caregivers and mental health
support for her Decades of work she and
her husband were awarded the highest
civilian honor in the US the
presidential medal of freedom work that
she continued to do into her '90s in
2021 The Carter celebrated their 75th
wedding anniversary the longest married
presidential couple in the country's
history and then Along Came Jimmy
Carter and my life's been an adventure
ever since thank you I love you a small
town woman whose compassion and
influence spans the globe and because of
her lives around it were
changed make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer